But you, you, you've made it out
perfect man, you know, so far, so far,
so far. Years will tell. Yeah.
Do you worry about it? Um,
not really. Um, like, uh, I try and keep
my mind active. I play a lot of chess.
How often you play chess? Every day.
Really? Yeah. Do you play online?
I play on line because whoever, whoever
jumps in the battle. How good are you?
Good. Yeah. Pretty good. Bully.
Did you play? You know, he,
he used to get mad at me cause I'd
go to his house and he'd be like,
you want to play chess? I
go, I don't know, just play
golf. Play. Just beat me him.
And he was like, get out of
here. Just move, bringing
somebody to complain to you.
Study chess. None as much as I should. Uh,
I just played often. And uh, you know,
when you play an offering there,
you know,
people will come out with the
same moves and it's like, oh,
I've seen this move before
and know what to do. Right.
Uh, but you know, it depends.
There's people that use the palms to,
to,
to wage war user the nights
or the bishops in combination.
So it really depends on what type
of player they are. You're right.
I'm a bully play.
I like playing right.
You know what he is the Joe Rogan of
pool to annex of chat. Well listen,
I can, my defense Lennox
challenged me. He watched her.
I was too late or just two people don't
challenge anybody on their own table.
That next challenge.
Giotto came a pool before the podcast
and Joe fucking cleared the table before
Lennox could get one shot.
Yeah, it was, it was good. It
was a, that was the warm up.
Well, I won the second game too, so yeah,
he doesn't need the second game as well.
I'm still warming up. I will go back.
He's got a, he's got the time deficit.
That's a crazy game though on that
table because that table has four inch
pockets. Yeah, that's my practice table.
Should show you a four inch bucket. Hey,
wait a minute. It, uh, I
have a regular table at home.
Well not a regular tape. It's a diamond's
got four and a half inch pockets.
It's still still a little tired and normal
po Po, like if you go to a pool hall,
they'll give you a five inch pocket
or a five and a half inch bolt.
[inaudible] much fucking,
I got the best. This table,
you can't mess. And it's dirty
right now too. So it's, it's even,
it's even like the cloth.
It's slow.
So balls don't drop unless they go right
through the same type of coffees up
blood supplies. Yes. That's
the most, that's the best one.
Yeah. It's the best. Yeah.
It's a great table.
That's a 1972 pool table and some guy
had it in his basement forever and my
friend Dani sold it to me. Yeah, the
guy just had it sitting in his basement.
It's in perfect condition. It's
a basement find. Yeah, man,
that's a hard table to get some
clarity around this California.
I love about the table.
Well guess what? What?
You don't want to have to walk around
and take the buckets of balls out of the
park. Yeah. That's annoying. Yeah, it's
like ball return. They're all there. Boom.
Yeah, those, those holes. When I got the
crown and I got those, it's annoying.
But you probably have like a
decorative pool table at the house
even though you've been
invited many times.
He's been to my house when it was with
my parents and they were kind of my house
as a, as a solo man. Now, um,
when you play chess, um, are
you like, do you get ranked?
Are you, uh, what it
is? Is your, your, um,
your points go up? So
I'm out of 11, 11, 7,000,
1100 right now. Sorry. What is that?
Well, the rankings are like, if, you know,
if you're up to 14, you're a master for,
so you're closing it on being a master.
Well, I wouldn't call me a master yet,
but you know, obviously if I get that,
I'm trying to get as high as possible,
but if someone talks shit
and they're like Linux,
I want to please not pull some
chats. You'd be like, oh, okay. Yeah.
See straight away what's one of
the most mentally intensive games?
It's probably one reason why you
stay so sharp, I would imagine. Yeah.
There's a time restriction.
10 minutes till you played that,
that we hit the slap the clock. Yeah.
We'll on 10 minutes for a mover.
10 minutes for the whole game.
For the whole game. Oh Dang.
Whoa. I'm the on the, um,
it's a fast game, you
know, on the computer.
Once you've made that move at the time
goes over. It just resets. So it's good.
Now. Do you ever go like to Washington
square park and play those dudes done?
Really? Yeah. Yeah. That's, that was, that
was fun. They talk a lot of Shit, Huh?
Oh yeah, they're good too.
They're good. The guy was playing,
was talking a lot of shit. Yeah.
Yeah. Did you beat him? Um, no.
Wow. You should've hit him. Why
did you have to ask that question?
It was just fun playing him.
You're gonna be a winner all the time.
And those guys are masters.
It's true. I mean, good. They
got nothing else going on.
Well, I mean, that's all they wanted to.
I mean, when you get really good at chess,
and I'm not really good at chess,
but I have friends that are,
they explained to you like
it becomes your whole life.
Like you start thinking like as
you're walking down the street,
you're thinking about chess.
He just,
it becomes a thing where
it's just everything.
It's all it's so it's such
an intense game. Yeah.
I played like four games a
day. Wow. Online Tam. Yeah.
What's your online name? Um, do
you use an online live? Yes, I do.
They don't use your real name, right? I'm
going to get it right now. It's uh, oh,
I made this name a long time ago and see,
yeah,
I'm Washington Square Park that playing
some masters at MC supernatural.
Those dudes love that game though, Matt.
I mean there's those guys who were there.
If you go there and there'll be there
every day, they fucking live for it.
You know, it's, um, it's one of
those things I really admire.
I really admire people that get her
get really, really good at chess.
Trying to find 2000 Inter,
2000.
What does that mean? Well, it was
supposed to be Interpol thousand.
It's like the name and to pull that
sounds official when when people were
playing, playing is integral. I think
this is the government I'm planning
Scia so if you're out there and you
play an inter 2000 you're playing Lennox
motherfucking Louis. Yeah, I
was going to put my real name,
but yeah, I don't want everybody
to try and beat the champ.
Well now they're going to send
us retired writing though.
Let it be known that Lennox Lewis is one
of those dudes that walks around with
no case on his iPhone two
and it smashed it smashed.
If I tell you what happens,
what happened?
I was doing something. Then all of a
sudden, you know, my wife said do this.
And I went, whew. And it
flew out of your hand.
But you have the biggest hands of any
human being I know. And A, and there's no,
there's no phone that's gonna be big
enough as you carry an iPad. Well,
let me tell you,
I don't know who makes these iPhones,
but they may come to slip out of your
hands. You know what I mean? They do.
They really do like put something on that.
That's grips have a case.
That's the first thing I did was
put a case on right. And then, um,
I forgot what I had to do. You have to
take it off to charge it up or some yeah,
some now he got the wrong case.
You get the wrong case.
Whoever sold your cases an Asshole,
I guess it doesn't have a thing where
you could just stick a hole in it.
Look at it. Never run jre case.
What could these guys challenged?
They're all challenging me or they now
I've got a boy called this game right
now. They're gonna come after you now
though. They find out they could play it.
I liked that they're doing it
while we're doing the podcast live.
I ain't you look, he's going to get
obsessed. The wheels are spinning.
The competitive drive. Let me tell you, my
wife gives me problems on this. He says,
you know,
he's playing chess that women don't
understand that you playing chess and
focusing. I'm trying to tell her,
listen, I'm up to this score point.
Don't interrupt because it affects
my score, but I need you now.
I needed to do we need to do this?
That's five minutes please. Five minutes.
You know she's looking at me weird, but
she's gotten better. She's actually,
are you playing chess? So and then she
leaves you alone. Yeah. That's good.
I think because I got mad a
couple of times a problem.
Yeah. Big bully with his wife. Jean.
Play chess with people other than Lennox.
No, I can't play chess, so I don't know.
I can't either. Maybe you and I played
together. We should really learn the gap.
Yeah.
Herded together.
I want to video this game. Do you have any
fucking disgusting? Well, you know what?
You could coach the game. No, this
is the first time I was, I was,
I would ever see a chess game
turned into checkers. Mm. Oh Man.
It's like I said, we're fighting. How,
how do you play this game again? How rude.
All this coming from man doesn't
really know how to play pool. Oh,
you're right. You're right. I play
billiards, billiards, pocket billiards.
You ever played three cushioned billiards?
You know what that is? One, two,
three and then you have to get it.
The whole of the holes,
is that the one with the bumpers?
Yeah.
Well the whole table so you have to
touch it. Yeah. Yeah. That's Russia.
Russian isn't, no, but I mean
Russians play it until a big,
it's real big in South America.
It's real big in Mexico.
It's real big in parts of
Europe. Real big in Asia. Yeah.
So different game there's
a to two different color
balls and like is he the two
white balls and a red ball or two red
balls and white ball and you got to,
or sometimes it's a yellow ball,
red ball and a white ball.
And the idea is you make contact with
one ball and then you have to hit three
cushions and then make contact
with the second ball. Wow. Yeah,
it's very complicated to watch. It's,
well, if you know how to play it,
it's good to watch. But if you
don't know how to play it, it's,
it's a thing about what I like about
pools. I liked when the ball's disappear,
like you make a ball goes away, it goes
in that hole by bitch. You sink the ball.
It's like a, it's got a
finality to it. It feels good.
But with that it just clicks. It's
like just Ding, Ding, ding, click.
But the people love it.
Love it.
It's a very intellectual game
cause it's all about geometry.
It's all angles and spin and you know,
I'm not good at that either. Yeah,
it's tricky. It's a tricky
game. I'm not good at it.